nous
vous
je t'ai donné des millions d
tu as mis dans un grand sac usées
mais plus tu as pris la route de mon
oubli je suis resté seul dans la vie je
m'assois sur la poubelle le roi
ce cuisine conserve
voix de la bière en bac 6
je mange des bonbons m'entraîner je
devais bien porter cheveux frisés du
mode hot air d'apple sont gelés
tu as oublié de chemise de nuit je passe
mes jours à dire
mais ta photo grandeur nature
a fini par manger
c'est moins qu'en radio en est
entrée centre a beaucoup plu
j'ai pas payer la note de gage
d'ailleurs je m'en servirai pas
le chagrin me fait comme une drogue
je voudrais pas t'oublier comme ça et ce
qu'il fait beau dans ton et le cinéma
sont in the knee
j'espère que tu te mets toujours au
premier rang près la sortie tu aimais
plus notre film
nous deux tu voyais plus de rose et bleu
j'aimerais bien raconter la faune
m'étendrai pas t'es trop loin
tu rentres pas trop tard j'espère me dit
d'une jolie passagère
y a des cheveux blancs et qui chante
bien mais je le ferai sa chanson demain
je crois que la vie c'est pas mon voyage
je plus envie de tourner mais pas
même le valais à me laisses ton
ils peuplent rien je suis habitué
je vais choisir la solitude par ex a tué
centimes
tout seul sans toi je vais essayer
je vais essayer de me supporter joué mon
va-tout avec la vie
en restant seul dans mon lit